let's say that no one has looked at
Alzheimer's or neurodegenerative disease
what do we need to know
I mean the first thing I think everybody
needs to know uh you're talking about
from a personal risk standpoint or just
understanding the disease personal risk
okay yeah so the first thing I you know
we want to know from all of our patients
is tell us your family history
right that you know there is a genetic
component to this disease so let's
understand what your susceptibility is
um would you ask them that ahead of just
saying go and get a genetic tester oh
absolutely yeah because the the I think
the family history is more telling than
the genetic test wow okay because
remember the genetic test we look at is
we look at the most common Gene which is
the gene that's easiest to test for
which is apoe there are a dozen other
genes that we look at but they're much
harder to sift for there aren't really
great commercial tests for them and God
knows if there's something lurking that
isn't part of this current Paradigm of
what we understand exactly did it show
up yeah if it showed up yeah so so right
out of the gate we want to know is is
um is dementia in your family if so what
type do we think it is so do we think
it's Alzheimer's dementia do we think
it's vascular dementia do we think it's
front to temporal lobe dementia do we
think it's Lewy Body dementia is there
Parkinson's disease
when you think about just comparing
Parkinson's disease Lewy Body dementia
Alzheimer's disease those are three
types of neurodegenerative diseases that
are on a spectrum where Alzheimer's is
the is the most cognitively destructive
Parkinson's is the most movement
movement destructive Lewy Body is taking
bits of both of their playbook right so
Lewy Body is destructive to both
movement and cognition well we want to
understand exactly what pattern you may
or may not be a part of we also want to
understand age of onset so
um tragically there there's a
fortunately very very rare but um you
know still unfortunately
prevalent form of early onset
Alzheimer's disease these are people who
are afflicted in their 40s and 50s is
that what Chris Hemsworth got no no he
got he realized something during that
day yeah Chris Chris learned that he has
two copies of the APO E4 Gene and the
APO E4 Gene is the most common genetic
uh you know the most common Gene
responsible for Alzheimer's disease but
not but it's not early it's not early
onset right it's a late onset
predisposition okay the early onset ones
are um called app
psen1 psen2
um so again those can be tested for we
don't normally test for those because
it's normally so Apparent from family
history uh of course now if we document
that we would of course test for it uh
tragically I think that's a variant of
Alzheimer's disease that is
um I think it's less clear how much you
can prevent lifestyle Independence right
whereas the one that Chris has and that
25 of the population has if they have
one copy of that Gene that's highly
amenable to prevention which really gets
to why we want to know this stuff you
want to know this stuff because one
sometimes that's the motivation people
need to take this seriously when they're
35 years old and young and
indestructible because that's the time
you want to actually act and secondly
there are certain things that we know
are even more important to people with
that genotype so it would factor into
what medications we might use to lower
cholesterol it might factor into how
much
omega-3 EPA and DHA we would want them
to take it might factor into other
choices we might make around nutrition
and even in people who are exercise time
limited it might factor into how we
prescribe exercise what are the biggest
prophylactics against mental degradation
over time
so I did recently did a podcast on this
um it's an AMA on my podcast that is 100
devoted to all interventions that
improve cognition And Delay the onset of
dementia
and I sort of broke it down into
here are the things for which there is
no ambiguity about the benefit
so enormous signal
I'm not going to talk much about them
because it's I'll give you you know the
basics on it and then I spent the entire
podcast talking about the gray stuff
where there's probably a benefit but
it's harder to quantify so you're asking
what are those things that I didn't
really talk about it's basically
exercise
um
uh lipid management
not having type 2 diabetes
and probably sleep
having adequate sleep those are those
are the No Regret moves that that have
enormous impact and it's probably in
that order
so it seems like looking at what we've
spoken about so far today and you
mentioned it earlier on you thought diet
was this unbelievably huge lever
it seems now that exercise is one of the
longest if not maybe the longest I think
it is that you're talking about I think
it is yeah I think the day certainly the
data would suggest that right so in
other words you go back to
so a hazard ratio is a very it's an
important tool in statistics to
understand the relative risk or benefit
of any intervention so a hazard ratio of
one means that this intervention has no
benefit and no harm a hazard ratio of
1.5
means this intervention is 50 percent
riskier than the Baseline a hazard ratio
of 0.75 means this intervention is 25
percent less risky right okay so
um when you just go off those numbers
what's the what's the hazard ratio of
smoking well it depends on the study but
it's about 1.4
so what that means is and that's for all
cause mortality so that means that if
you're if you compare a smoker to a
non-smoker all things equal at any point
in time that smoker is 40 more likely to
die in a given year than the non-smoker
it's devastating right if you look at
hypertension
it's about 1.2 1.21 so having high blood
pressure means you're about 20 to 21
percent more likely to die in a given
year than someone who's identical to you
in every way except they don't have high
blood pressure if you look at somebody
with you know atherosclerosis so
Advanced cardiovascular disease it's
about 1.25
um if you look at somebody with
end-stage kidney disease so someone
who's on dialysis it's like
2.75 that means there are 175 percent
more likely to die in a given year than
someone who's not in end-stage renal
disease
so
now start comparing all of these other
interventions I'm talking about well
let's go back to the VO2 max if you take
somebody who's in the bottom 25 of
fitness
which by definition 25 of the population
are and you compare them to somebody
who's in the top two percent for their
age
it's a five
that has a ratio is five
so it means it's 400 percent difference
in mortality
if I take somebody who is in the bottom
quartile of strength and compare them to
the top quartile of strength it's about
three as a hazard ratio
so when you go through these metrics of
exercising or muscle mass or strength or
cardiorespiratory Fitness it just dwarfs
everything else including diabetes
including smoking so and again this
isn't a zero-sum game like the goal is
get as many things on your side as
possible be of normal weight don't have
diabetes be sleeping well don't smoke
but be strong as hell have a high VO2
max I mean you want you want to Stack
the odds as much in your favor as
possible there's no guarantee in life
and this there's still an enormous
stochastic random bad luck component to
life I could walk out of here and get
hit by a car but I'd like to control
what I can control
heart disease is the biggest killer on
the planet at the moment bar none
why are our hearts so fragile
I mean actually I would argue they're
not right if you consider what your
heart is doing right you know it's like
this amazing organ that is
beating non-stop without any instruction
from you consciously and has this
remarkable capacity to respond to your
autonomic nervous system On Demand right
someone runs through this door and
startles us our heart rates are going to
Skyrocket instantly we don't even need
to tell it something bad is happening
right I you know you you go to you know
get stem cells at elevation your heart
rate knows to get jacked uh so so so so
so this this thing isn't a remarkable
muscle
um but
it has
um it has a narrow blood supply
you know so
um
and it doesn't have a remarkable
capacity to revascularize itself that's
probably its biggest drawback
you know other muscles in our body uh
have in much easier time undergoing
angiogenesis
so if you know if you suffered kind of
uh you know an occlusion of of a blood
vessel a small blood vessel in your leg
it wouldn't cause as much trouble
because you'd have kind of an easier
time creating collateral flow around it
but in the heart that's that's that's
less the case and of course the stakes
are much higher you probably wouldn't
notice it if a you know
a silver dollar sized patch of your quad
stopped working it wouldn't reek as much
Havoc as if an equal sized patch of your
left ventricle stopped working
um so the problem is that
Evolution didn't really care about
atherosclerosis that's that's really the
problem right so atherosclerosis is
driven by factors that Evolution wasn't
at all
caring about because they didn't
interfere with reproductive Fitness so
smoking high blood pressure and high APO
B are the main drivers of
atherosclerosis and none of those things
were on Evolution's radar in fact you
could argue
um High APO B for a period of our human
history would have been beneficial APO B
being the lipoprotein that wraps around
LDL and vldl would have played an
important role in a scarce nutrient
environment which we were in up until a
few hundred years ago
and today of course it creates a problem
right today those apob particles those
LDL particles are carrying cholesterol
into our artery walls and our immune
system which by the way is doing the
best job it can like the little train
that could is treating that as though
it's a foreign Invader and mounting an
enormous immune response and it's that
immune response it's actually
leading to the creation of plaque that
ultimately results in a heart attack so
when it comes to heart disease
it seems like there's two broad elements
here one would be restricting the things
which cause risk and the other would be
improving yourself from Baseline what
are the big buckets in either of those
you mentioned smoking smoking blood
pressure and APO B so if you just took
those three things off the table it's
very hard to imagine how you can get
atherosclerosis so if you don't smoke if
you maintain a blood pressure at or
below 120 over 80 and if your APO B is
maintained at the physiologic level that
kids have you can't get atherosclerosis
how does someone know about their ipob
simple blood test cost about 12 bucks
okay and how often do you need to get
that done uh I mean I probably check
mine three or four times a year I
probably check mine three times a year
um yeah and if it came back and said
this is high then you would try to ask
the question why is it high how much of
this is going to be fixable by diet how
much of this is going to be fixable
pharmacologically truthfully to get to
the levels that are necessary to
eradicate atherosclerosis for most
people does require pharmacologic
intervention this is probably in in my
opinion if antibiotics represent the
biggest win of medicine 2.0 uh
anti-lipid therapy would be the second
biggest win okay that's stopping the bad
yep improving the good for the hot yeah
so again exercise not surprising
um and probably more so the benefit on
cardio here but you're probably going to
see more of a the data would certainly
suggest that cardio is the more
important exercise of the two but again
I always caution people you're not just
feeding your heart you got to worry
about your brain you got to worry about
your body so we're never going to get
into the to a cardio or strength
Paradigm it's and it's always going to
be and but just to be clear the cardio
training probably has a better impact on
the heart
um um
sleep
so uh lo you know poor sleep has
devastating impact on the heart probably
through sympathetic overtone uh
hypercortisonemia things like that so
stress becomes another thing that really
matters it's kind of again it's one of
these sort of fuzzy terms that kind of
seems like oh yeah yeah stress I'm sure
but but I think the data are very clear
that high levels of cortisol
um are are really damaging to coronary
arteries
um and then again nutrition kind of
factors in probably to the pharmacologic
strategy so there's no question that
um for you know if you're if you were
saying
what would be the most Draconian
nutrition step I could take to minimize
my lipids
um you could take that step but you're
probably creating three other problems
in its wake right so if you went on like
a 10 fat diet
you would probably drop your lipid
levels to you know very healthy levels
the problem is what other problems would
you how do you hormones look yeah how do
your hormones look how does your muscle
mass all these other things and so what
you call it lifelike only having temps
on fat in your diet right so the way I
think about it is
when I can use so so if I can use
pharmacology to solve a problem without
creating another problem that's a far
better use case than using nutrition to
solve a problem that creates a whole
bunch of other problems because you can
be more targeted yep yep understood
that's interesting what's happening
people if you enjoyed that then press
here for the full unedited episode and
don't forget to subscribe
face